[Professor Doctor Jakob Erdheim, Prosector, City Hospital, Vienna, September 1933]
[City Hospital, Vienna]
[Camera pans around the outside of the hospital.]
[Doctors are gathered around a corpse lying on a table, talking amongst themselves.]
[At another table, two more doctors are cutting and organizing organs.]
[One doctor slices a crescent shape into a man's chest from shoulder to shoulder.]
[The doctor then slices a line straight down from the center of the crescent to the bottom of the abdomen.]
[He pauses to turn and speak to others.]
[Other doctors then help to pull the skin apart to expose the organs.]
[Two doctors work to slice tissue and skin off of the rib cage.]
[The skin is then peeled back further around the throat and lower abdominal muscles.]
[Two doctors carefully cut through the rib cage and remove it from the body.]
[The primary doctor then begins to cut out the intestines and other major organs, placing them off to the side.]
[The doctor rinses his hands in a bowl of water near the feet of the corpse to remove excess tissue.]
[He speaks to others preparing to work on the corpse.]
[Two doctors cut out the lungs and place them on a separate table.]
[The primary doctor then makes an incision in the lungs.]
[The doctor exchanges words with one of the doctors standing nearby, possibly explaining the process to him.]
[The skin on the face has been peeled back and now the doctor is removing flesh near the nose.]
[The doctor makes several incisions into the skull.]
[He peers down at the skull, then looks up and around.]
[Another person hands the primary doctor a hammer and chisel which he uses to crack the skull.]
[He uses the chisel to create more openings on the sides of the skull.]
[The top of the skull is removed and the doctor uses his finger and scalpel to carve out the brain.]
[The doctor picks away pieces of the skull from the brain and places it on the table.]
[The primary doctor begins to speak to the other doctors again.]
[The doctor continues his explanations as they observe the way he is handling the brain.]
[The primary doctor rubs his fingers along the different regions of the brain and turns to his left to speak.]